Ever since The Walking Dead first aired in 2010,
the creative minds at AMC had been quietly sowing
seeds that connected the zombie series with
another AMC success story, Breaking Bad. So,
what does Walter White's meth-infused power trip
have to do with surviving the end of the world?
Ever since the spinoff series of Fear
the Walking Dead arrived on the scene,
it's been clear that The Walking Dead universe
was more than just a single show set
between Atlanta and Washington D.C.
This was confirmed when AMC Network CEO Josh
Sapan announced in early September 2018 that
the folks at AMC had plans for the universe that
extended, quote, "over the next decade plus."
While this may have seemed odd in the shadow
of the show's faltering ratings at the time,
it kind of makes sense.
The idea of a long term goal that spans beyond
the scope of a single film or series is par for
the course in Hollywood. Cross-pollinating
universes is totally in these days,
so a connection between AMC
shows is hardly surprising.
What's a bit more interesting, though, is
the not-quite-confirmed larger crossover
that integrates Breaking Bad
into The Walking Dead universe,
a phenomenon fondly nicknamed
the "Breaking Dead Theory."
It's been loosely confirmed
by showrunner Dave Erickson,
and here's the skinny on
how the two shows line up.
It didn't take long for The Walking Dead
to start incorporating elements of their
runaway hit Breaking Bad into their
fledgling zombie apocalypse series.
In the second episode of season two, Daryl
Dixon can be seen rifling through a clear bag.
The contents comprise his brother Merle's
stash, most of which is in pill bottles.
However, tucked at the bottom of the bag
is a hefty dose of some blue crystals.
The shot immediately grabs your
attention, as Daryl casually lists
"crystal" among the gathered narcotics. Of
course, the prize for the most famous blue
crystals in history has to go to Mr. White's
Sky Blue. By the end of Breaking Bad, the
stuff was sought after all over the world, so its
presence in Georgia wouldn't be particularly odd.
The connection hung there for a bit until none
other than Walking Dead creator Robert Kirkman
confirmed that the Easter
egg was there on purpose.
"It ain't cloudy or dirty or nothin.
Just the right shade of blue."
Another possible link that was picked up
on in the Walking Dead season 4 episode
"Still" involved Walter White's
associate, Mr. Jesse Pinkman.
This one came during that chunk of time when Daryl
and Beth were romping around the countryside,
surviving, being moody, and bonding
like a couple of cute misfits.
In one scene Daryl tells a story about his
brother Merle before everything went south.
"Merle had this dealer. This janky
little white guy. A tweaker."
Fans were quick to jump on the description
as fitting Pinkman rather neatly.
The speculation became more intriguing
a little further into the story,
when Daryl explained an altercation
with the fellow in question.
"Then he pulls a gun, sticks it right here.
He says, 'I'm gonna kill you, bitch.'"
Between the description and that line, it's
hard not to start drawing a connection.
Did Merle work for the nefarious
Jesse Pinkman once upon a time?
Perhaps. Although, at another point in
the story Daryl refers to the guy's kids.
Guess we'll never know.
Another Easter egg appeared during
season 3 of Fear the Walking Dead
hidden in plain sight. As the
group entered a bustling bazaar,
a song could be heard blaring
over the radio. It was in Spanish,
and to an uninformed viewer did little more than
add a mariachi-style splash of color to the scene.
However, for those intimately acquainted with
Walter White's tragic story arc, the song had
a much deeper meaning and an undeniable
connection to the Breaking Bad universe.
We're talking about "Negro y
Azul: The Ballad of Heisenberg."
The song appeared as a cold open in Breaking
Bad and is written about Walter White,
a.k.a. Heisenberg, chronicling his
rise to power against established
drug cartels and predicting his eventual demise.
The song is clearly specific to Breaking Bad,
and its appearance on Fear the Walking Dead was
a clear shoutout to the connection that
the shows share. Showrunner Erickson was
referring to this scene in particular when
he confirmed that the nod was intentional,
adding more cargo to the runaway train
that is the Breaking Dead Theory.
In season 4, as he continues to break bad, Walter
White has a growing infatuation with indulging
his reckless nature. Instead of returning a car
for an exorbitant restocking fee, for instance,
White simply blows it up. And what about that
car? A 2009 Dodge Challenger. Red with a double
black racing stripe straight down the center.
That is, until it was blown to smithereens.
And it wasn't the last time one of
these cars would appear on an AMC show.
Fast forward to exactly one apocalypse later.
In the first season of The Walking Dead,
another Challenger makes an appearance, this time
roaming the streets of Atlanta. The car
in question is, once again, a 2009 model.
Some have taken a gigantic leap, assuming that the
mysterious Glenn who sold Walter the car in New
Mexico was none other than Glenn Rhee, who fixed
it up and drove it to Georgia. A more reasonable
explanation might be that Glenn Rhee the car
salesman was simply infatuated with that model.
Either way, this nod from the new show
to the old seems clearly intended.
While the little Breaking Bad Easter
eggs sprinkled throughout The Walking
Dead universe are fun to point out, the real
heart and soul of the Breaking Dead Theory
actually rests on a crossover that's even
more sinister. It suggests that Blue Sky
doesn't merely link the two worlds, but that
it's the cause of the zombie apocalypse.
While the theory hasn't been made official in
any formal way, it also hasn't been denied by the
creators of either show. On the contrary, they've
stoked the fires. Walking Dead creator Robert
Kirkman said, albeit a bit tongue-in-cheek,
quote, "That's canon, it's confirmed!"
Producer Gale Ann Hurd, when responding
to the question of what caused the virus,
stated flatly, quote, "The meth
from Breaking Bad, for sure."
On the other side of the aisle, Breaking Bad's
Vince Gilligan responded to
the speculation by saying:
"I love that theory. That was a
kick. They're two great shows,
The Walking Dead and Fear the Walking Dead."
Bryan Cranston added,
"Walt is dead, so he could be a
zombie right now. Heisenberg zombie!"
Gale was a pretty sweet character on Breaking
Bad. He was one of the few people who could
rival White's scientific prowess, and he could
brew some darn good coffee. In fact, the man had
turned the latter into a science project with an
elaborate machine that took volume, temperature,
acidity, and tannins, all into account in
the pursuit of brewing the perfect cup.
"Oh my God. That is the best
coffee I've ever tasted."
While his death may have left the Breaking
Bad crew with cups of Folgers sludge,
it appears it wasn't the last time the scientist's
magically caffeine-infused machine was used.
In the third episode of season 3 on
The Walking Dead, Merle, the Governor,
and Milton all gather in his
lab. While they're talking,
in the background is none other
than Gale's coffee machine.
The question is: How did it get there?
This tie-in between Breaking Bad
and The Walking Dead goes back
further than you might think. Season 9
of The Walking Dead didn't just see the
departure of characters like Rick Grimes. It
also saw the introduction of the Whisperers.
In episode ten, we saw a great deal of their
leader Alpha's backstory through the testimony
of her daughter Lydia. During those scenes,
both of Lydia's parents are seen singing.
"Lydia, oh! Lydia, say have you met
Lydia, oh! Lydia the tattooed lady. [...]"
The tune is fitting for the scene as the
girl looks for solace amidst the horrors of
the end of the world. But it wasn't just
a well-placed musical number — it also,
of course, harkened back to Breaking Bad.
In the waning moments of
Breaking Bad's last episode,
Walter White stands in the midst of the carnage
he's created in his final act of vengeance.
As he parts ways with Jesse Pinkman for the
last time, a cellphone starts to ring on the
lifeless body of Todd that lies in front of him.
The tune on the cell? "Lydia the Tattooed Lady."
"Lydia, oh! Lydia, say have you met
Lydia, oh! Lydia the tattooed lady."
It added an abrupt splash of color to
the series' swan song as White picked up
and informed yet another Lydia on the other
end of the call that her death was imminent.
The connections between AMC's two
monumental worlds are too numerous to deny,
and yet the creators of both series
have yet to openly steer into the skid.
Walter White's world has continued on in the
form of Better Call Saul and the full-length
feature El Camino released in 2019. In addition,
The Walking Dead has Fear the Walking Dead,
a triple-header of films in the works, and
several more confirmed Walking Dead series!
With all the material being produced, a
marriage of the two universes could be a match
made in heaven. After all, Breaking Bad
hardly closed up shop before it became
one of the cult classics of our time. And
the fandom still surrounding The Walking
Dead could continue breathing life into this
beloved world of the dead for years to come.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.